[Music]
Bloomberg first reported and axios was
able to independently confirmed that
President Joe Biden in his new White
House budget is going to be proposing a
number of new taxes I am going to tell
you what they are and then we will
discuss whether they are likely to
become a reality axios writes the new
budget request to Congress set to be
released uh Thursday includes a 25
minimum tax on the richest
0.01 percent of Americans This is a
billionaire tax it would also increase
the top tax rate for those Americans
making four hundred thousand dollars a
year up to 39.6 percent from 37 percent
that was the rate prior to Trump's 27
tax bill 2017 tax bill it would go back
to that prior rate it would raise income
levies on corporations and billionaires
and it would set the corporate tax rate
at 28 still below the 35 percent rate
that was in place prior to Trump's 2017
tax law that is not the only thing that
Joe Biden plans to do he also plans an
increased Medicare tax remember when we
talk about social security and Medicare
sometimes people forget about the
Medicare piece uh what Joe Biden wants
to do
is increase the Medicare tax rate from
3.8 to 5 on income exceeding 400 000 per
year and it would apply to both salaries
as well as capital gains it would likely
increase tax revenues by over 117
billion dollars over 10 years so about
11.7 billion a year according to Prior
estimates from last month by the tax
policy Center so a couple different
things is Joe Biden sticking to his
promise not to increase taxes on people
making under four hundred thousand
dollars a year by all reasonable
assessments of these proposals the
answer is yes Joe Biden is not raising
taxes on anyone making under 400k
secondly is this likely to pass and the
answer is no I made this analysis When
Donald Trump would release his budgets
and it is the same analysis when Joe
Biden releases his budgets White House
budgets are political documents
political documents you have to get this
through the House of Representatives
currently controlled by Republicans in
order to make it a reality and so this
is a sort of wish list this is what you
could say Joe Biden would do
if he could wave a magic wand and to be
totally honest sometimes presidents
include things in White House budgets
that they wouldn't actually do if they
had full power to do it they included in
the budget as a signal a virtue signal
we have to admit knowing that it's not
going to pass which category are these
proposals under well we don't know
because we know that it is a White House
budget which is a political document so
it will be interesting to see however
are there negotiations to be had where
Republicans who control the house would
be willing to come to the table on some
of these proposals from Joe Biden in
exchange for what well we don't really
know in exchange for what we will be
watching it but so far these proposals
as unlikely as they are to become the
law
are keeping Joe Biden adhered to the
promise he made about Americans making
under four hundred thousand dollars per
year
if you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below